what do you see what happens to our
country because people can feel it
billions and billions of dollars are
being poured back into the United States
the stock market has added more than
eight trillion dollars in new wealth
unemployment claims are at a forty-five
year low which is something after years
of stagnation the United States is once
again experiencing strong economic
growth the stock market is smashing one
record after another the stock market is
up since my election almost 50 percent
president talks about the stock market a
lot he did not talk about it in the
speech today one of the reasons was what
you're seeing on the screen today the
stock market dropped almost 1,600 points
before regaining and finishing at about
almost 1,200 points down on the Dow and
there you see the rest of the markets
but as the president notes in the White
House put out late this afternoon since
the election the Dow specifically has
seen a major increase and obviously
today you see the top of the mountain
fall off and many people say this won't
be the last time in a volatile situation
today was the single biggest one-day
point drop ever but not the single
biggest percentage drop in the markets
so what about all of this let's bring in
our panel guy Benson political editor at
townhall.com
Moe Alethea executive director of the
Georgetown Institute of Politics and
Kimberly Strasse a member of the
editorial board at The Wall Street
Journal Kimberly let me start with you
your thoughts on this as you look at the
big picture of the economy and and what
happens on a market day like this that
obviously jars a lot of people who are
in the markets well I think the
important thing to remember Brett is
that the economy has not materially
changed from Friday until Monday so
there isn't necessarily an economic
reason behind this or for any reason to
panic
more likely look people have been
talking that the markets was potentially
a little overvalued and due for a
correction last week also we saw some
rising
yields that makes people think inflation
that makes something higher interest
rates that makes the stock market look a
little less attractive some of this
might also bend the machines taking over
at a certain point when the market drops
enough they have all these algorithms
that kick in and that could have
exacerbated it but I think the important
point is that the economy itself is
still very strong and it gets to the the
lack of wisdom of the president using
the stock market as an indicator of that
health
yeah which sometimes you know Moe
politicians often try to stay away from
using the market because of just this
reason that said if you think about it
that sometimes the increase of
confidence in an economy can actually
cause some fear about what the Fed is
going to do as far as interest rates and
I think a lot of people are concerned
about that and I agree completely with
the point that Kimberly just made this
president you know you live by the sword
you die by the sword you put it out
there as as a single greatest indicator
of your economic prowess then when you
take a hit when the stock market takes a
hit you got an answer for that too and
so I think he's he's facing that now to
look is this gonna change the political
dynamic of heading into the midterm year
at all this the single day drop mm
probably not I do think the economy is
going to be the single biggest catalyst
of what happens politically in the
midterms moving forward over the course
of the next year but it's not going to
be fought on this ground unless we
continue to see many more days like this
one well guy if that's true and what Moe
is saying and the economy becomes as it
often does in the elections the biggest
thing you know the White House is saying
for all of those workers who have the
thousand dollar checks or the the
workers who see increase in their
paychecks as of this month that's
changing the dynamic it is changing the
dynamic and I think the Republicans
should be hammering at this every single
day and the Democrats have taken a very
strange approach to this good news for
the American people and for millions of
American workers they're demeaning in
many cases the crumbs
that people are getting in the form of
bonuses and enhanced benefits 401k
matches expanded operations and even
what people are seeing in their
paychecks these paid bumps as a result
of the tax cuts that Democrats
themselves had argued hysterically in
many cases would never materialize under
a bill that was Armageddon and the end
of the world the proof is now in the
pudding and in the form of paychecks and
I think for Democrats to try to very
quickly pivot from this is a terrible
bill that will hurt working-class and
middle-class people too well the good
news for working-class and middle-class
people really isn't good enough news
it's just crumbs and they need to
understand they shouldn't get too
excited that's a tough that's a tough
little adjustment to make I think
rhetorically look I think Democrats
actually have I think Democrats actually
have plenty of room here to go after
this this tax law I agree with you
trivial I trivializing the the benefits
as crumbs probably wasn't the smartest
way but what there's plenty of data out
there and plenty of anecdotes the
president's fond of putting out all
these anecdotes of bonuses that people
have received but there's plenty of
anecdotes of layoffs corporations that
took the tax windfall closing down
factories laying workers off since the
bill became law 40,000 people have lost
their jobs and nine billion dollars have
been invested into corporate stock
buybacks and so for Democrats to be able
to point out the growing disparity there
the the consequence of people the CEOs
laying workers off in order to line
their own pockets is a much I think more
potent strategy for them to have this
fight than trivializing the thousand
dollar bonuses that some workers are
getting well Kimberly if that was
accurate across the board I think that
you wouldn't see some of the polls that
you're seeing for example Monmouth has a
new poll out about the tax law and the
question is your view of the tax reform
plan and you look at the poll now as
opposed to what it was in December of
2017 and the disapproval has been erased
and it's essentially approved disapprove
and
matches that matches almost every poll
and then you look at the generic ballot
between Democrats and Republicans it's
now down to two points in most polls
yeah no this is the best thing the
Republicans could have done this was the
biggest complaint about the Obama
economy is that it wasn't horrible
horrible but it didn't really offer a
lot of inspiration there was not a lot
of good news it just bumped along and
you know there's always gonna be an
anecdote here or there of some layoffs
or something but overall the question is
are people generally benefiting from
this bill and you know this is why the
president has so much he could be
talking about not the stock market but
look even the stock market people don't
tend to feel that immediately anyway yes
they'd like to see their 401k going up
their 529s for their kids but it's
always something that's in the future or
mostly in the future what they care
about is the day to day paycheck and the
fundamentals are so strong and getting
stronger we're only a month into this
too by the way but we're not even
beginning to get see some of the
expansions that economies have that
different companies have promised and
investments that they're going to make
so those are the things Republicans if
they continue to hit on that it's gonna
be the strongest ammunition that they'll
be able to take in to these midterms
nothing else will compare